[Music]
Vasanti on CBS it is the Grammy salute
to the Bee Gees it was Barry Gibb and so
many incredible artists my stomach hurts
just thinking about this because Celine
Dion of course is right at the top of
this was a Nancy I had a dream come true
just for yourself
oh my gosh I was backstage where
everybody and I mean everybody myself
included got beat you think I just have
this involuntary urge to do this
I just do that I didn't but it's a
bucket-list moment for sure and Celine
has a special connection with the
brothers give the BG's wrote me a song
in 97 I did an album called let's talk
about love and this thing into wet with
me they wrote me that song you were
singing directly to Barry and I felt
like you guys really had a moment there
at the end I really wanted to have a
moment here because and we should all
have a moment we should never wait to
have a moment
let's bits to it time is precious
Barry is the only surviving VG's member
Mars died in 2003 Robin in 2012
backstage I spoke with all the
performers excited to be singing in this
all-star tribute you don't know just
remember those beautiful harmonies that
the brothers melodies were absolutely
gorgeous
Saturday Night Fever turns 40 this year
at the Grammys Barry told us ten years
earlier the Bee Gees were just three
brothers trying to make it as a band I'm
sure in many ways a bittersweet looking
back well of course it is but you know
it's not just an anniversary for fever
it's see it's the 50th anniversary of
the BG you know the other of the year we
were named the vivaz you hear those
songs too then you're like oh my god
this is such a yet it doesn't happen a
lot salute my brother that's my mission
they know how much I miss him I feel
like I communicate with them I always
worry about one of them with things or
what more is good things
[Applause]
Oh Barry I think they would say we've
done pretty good now just because we
can't get enough of the Bee Gees here's
this a remastered 40th anniversary
soundtrack of Saturday Night Fever is
dropping April 21st
along with timeless which is a new BG
Greatest Hits outlet
[Music]